is there a connection between the terror
and the religion of Islam were said that
those people coming from what kind of
education is that a hat how come that's
when it's last night or Charlie Hebdo or
what happened in Beirut you know there
are always the same people
the main problem in my point of view is
the problem of Education why it started
from the education because in some
places in some places there is a biased
education the education is based on
exclusion where anta tolerance I'm in
many places we have we have to focus on
program of education that's why that's
why in another panel I proposed an Arab
Marshall Plan which would lead
essentially with the good governance and
education because new good governance
and education the day and the open
education is essential to prevent such
kind of barbarism it starts with
education and then the development in
some various areas because also positive
poverty increases prove such kind of
behavior but just to understand you
correctly are you saying that the
fanatics are educated to become fanatic
yes yes I think that very clearly
because there is a kind of Education
which profits leads to such kind of
barbarism and such kind of planet ISM an
education of exclusion and they not
recognize the other they are the this
this is a bias education and we have to
start from here what do you think is
that education
well as an educator myself I wish I
could agree but the fact is that quite a
number of the people who have
perpetrated the terrorist activities in
Europe or indeed who have gone to the
Middle East to join the forces of
Islamic state are well-educated
Europeans children of immigrants those
arrested in Britain or in France
connected with this kind of crimes went
to French schools educated in
egalitarian et song in a secular lay
environment and none of this has
protected them now one should of course
say that five or six percent or more of
the population of France are Muslim and
what we are talking about are fifty a
hundred thousand ten thousand a tiny
proportion it's will be extraordinary to
expect an educational system to be able
to get it right as it were one hundred
percent but you know let me finish the
second in Europe we had terrorism as
well European terrorism in Italy the Red
Brigades the baader-meinhof gang in the
Irish the IRA the Basque terrorist
terrorism is not something which is only
in the Middle East we now know of it and
these people the Red Brigades the
baader-meinhof gang were perfectly well
educated they were taught probably Latin
and philosophy and something about Hagar
and Emmanuel Kant and yet they became
terrorists so it can't be an explanation
it's it's always tempting for
intellectuals to want to blame education
to want to blame media but I would also
add another factor in the you know why
fanaticism appears and that's politics
and ideology but particularly
particularly even practical politics you
know one of the mistakes I think we've
made in Europe over the last 50 60 or
years is to assume and even actually the
nature of your question the structure of
this conference reflects that it's that
we assume that we've changed human
nature and we've eliminated barbarism
and
fanaticism and we've created a
civilization that doesn't have the
minute word no actually what we did is
we created a situation in which those
things were you know that it wasn't
advantageous to be a barbarian and it
wasn't you know useful to be a fanatic
and it didn't get you anywhere and it
didn't create a career for you and it
eliminated those kinds of possibilities
whereas as you just pointed out Hitler
created a political system in which
being the more fanatical you were the
more the origin of this political as we
see on the Internet connect the Nazi era
there is the origin we know very well
what it comes the era also somewhere and
it was the creation of a structure and a
system in a set of institutions which
favored fanatical views you know one of
the things you learn quickly as
everybody at this table knows when you
when you read archives or when you read
the history of totalitarian regimes
nobody with a tiny number of exceptions
you know very free nobody who's acting
as a you know as a gulag commander or
working at a concentration camps thinks
that what they're doing is evil they
think what they're doing is good they're
doing it for a higher cause as I was
saying that civilization is the correct
one but they think that it's the the
because the the politics of the system
is such that that's the behavior that's
encouraged and created it's not just
about education it's also but political
institutions it's about incentives it's
about I mean it's about some very
mundane things you know when you look at
when you look at the opposite problem
you know who resists fanaticism in a for
example in a totalitarian society the
people who resist are often people who
have nothing to lose you know they're
young you know they're outsiders they're
you know they're they're there for some
reason outside people living about
poverty poverty people who have children
to raise people who have mothers to get
medicine for you know they need to be
within a system and working
problems but this is this is the reason
because for for special Institute of
Education of these systems the National
Socialists created own schools own
systems of Education not to produce the
killers but to produce an atmosphere of
a society who's willing to accept the
killers as a part of their own yes this
is trying to create a state in which yes
and this is the national socialist
education system Wars and is remaining
is dangerous and I agree with you it is
not possible to start such a movement as
a big political movement without to
change schools and universities during
Nazi era the they made big plans how to
change their systems to create another
attitude of mind to create an atmosphere
of acceptance for violence as a part of
normal life and the normal politics and
but sorry about blaming the education
system for Nazi Germany seems to me a
little bit far-fetched Hitler takes over
in 1933 even assuming and it can't be so
that he transforms the education system
within a month of him taking power it
means that by 1943 when the the deaf
camp are in full swing the people who
went through the education renounce the
education system were ten years older
now we know it's not true the people who
did the killing did not go through the
education system in Nazi Germany they'd
become barbarians already partly because
of the First World War
partly because of the unemployment
partly because of the propaganda
partly because of the Second World War
the war is one of the most fantastic
mechanism to transform normal human
beings into barbarians the education
system of course country
but frankly it's not the main cause also
because they were part of a political
organization there was a lap career
ladder they could climb so there was a
life in other words their behavior was
legitimized yes that is the key thing
that there is a group of people who say
well done this is what you should be
doing you should kill Jews or infidels
or whatever or bourgeois or whatever it
is defense
let me I want now to take a role a very
difficult and a rescuer I would like to
be advocate as a devil's advocate we
speak you mentioned the topic is are the
super barriers but don't you think that
we should also discuss what does it mean
a barbarian what does it mean for whom
is it that only a European Europe
European centric point of view well when
we speak barbarian very well then often
we are barbarians mm maybe we are events
to those educated person who committed
suicide well it's now you remember there
was probably whoever God knows in
sixteenth century was a debate between
sepulveda and the Bartolome de las casas
after conquering mexico and las casas
you wanted to defend the native people
and those his opponents were even though
they were surprised so we are not
entitled to use them as dressed animals
for them they were already death animals
not human beings well if you mentioned
the Gemayel education well yes in this
respect I will I will share your opinion
because people who treated me well in
outfits was involved
they didn't consent me to be a human
being for them I was allows a bigger
figure a cockroach and what do you do
with it
you step on you annihilated it you
suffocated so I was only insect and this
is what were right this is a way how to
they started teaching it the kids from
the beginning before to to a great
president
jemelle about point of view the
education for me it's very important to
be careful don't take the world
education in ostrich education mean a
lot of thing it's not mean the degrees
of instruction that were culture yes my
own education is really important I
agree what emergency what is mean
barbarians that's really important
and I grew up with my family in Mali and
in Mauritania I am Muslim and my mother
and my father did teach me they educated
me how to grow up how to understand
another person I am the result of this
concept of the world come from Muslim
education to situation exist very
strongly in West society it's a fear of
immigration and of terrorism and fear
creates the wrong conception of many
thing and the our problem is the fear
it's also in my country fear of the
poverty poverty and but when I listened
today almost all this morning it was
really really strong and interesting for
me because he talked about I learned I
learned two things this morning towards
is the the concept of compromise and the
curiosity when the compromise don't
exist one the curiosity not exists is
terrible the curiosity and compromise
need any plus in this world not only
this part become Isis today European
people on West people they need also
compromise and curiosity
to come to us
you